[Music]
the police chief in rochester new york
has stepped down along with his command
staff
following days of protests over the
death of daniel prude
fruit as you may recall died a week
after this confrontation with police in
march captured him on body
cam video he was naked at the time and
appeared to be suffering a mental health
crisis
the demonstrations have focused not just
on this incident but how long it took to
come to light
hood's family filed a federal lawsuit
yesterday alleging a cover-up
jerika duncan has been following this
story jerica good morning to you why is
the chief stepping aside now
good morning well you know this police
chief had been with the police
department for 20 years and he accused
his critics
of trying to destroy his character and
his integrity over how he handled
the investigation into daniel prude's
death now the mayor maintains that she
did not ask the chief to step down
i can assure this community that i am
committed to instituting the reforms
necessary in our police department
rochester mayor lovely warren confirming
tuesday that police chief laurent
singletary along with several top
officers
had given up their leadership positions
i know that there are many questions
but this just occurred and honestly i do
not have
the answers the outgoing chief said he
would not stand for quote
the mischaracterization and the
politicization of the actions he took in
his handling of daniel pruitt's death
investigation
[Music]
i mean it god bless y'all last week the
family released the body camera footage
five months after prude's death the next
day mayor warren suspended the seven
officers she says were involved in the
arrest
a week of protests has turned rochester
into the latest flashpoint of summer
demonstrations
over racial injustice following the
death of george floyd
[Music]
crude was pinned to the ground with a
spit hood on his head for about three
minutes
seven days later he died his death was
ruled a homicide by asphyxiation
and the medical examiner listed the
hallucinogen pcp
as a contributing factor what we want is
for our police officers to act like
professionals
and that's what we're seeking to bring
about
reforms that professionalize the
rochester police department
the prude family lawsuit alleges the
police department tried to cover up the
true nature of crude's death
but if you you told her that a person
od'd while being arrested did you know
that he was being held down and all the
other stuff
yes singletary is the latest in a list
of police chiefs to resign or retire
during the protests that have swept the
country
renee hall the first black woman to lead
the dallas police department
submitted her resignation tuesday she
had been criticized for a spike in crime
and her handling of the protests in
kentucky yvette gentry will come
out of retirement and become the first
black woman to lead louisville's police
department
she'll head a beleaguer department's
handling of the killing of briana taylor
the 26 year old emt was shot and killed
by police
during a no knock raid at her apartment
when we're wrong
i'm going to stand here like a woman a
grown woman
and tell you we made mistakes
now the police union in rochester new
york stands behind those seven officers
who were
suspended saying that they were
following training
as for that lawsuit from the prude
family they named the city of rochester
chief singletary
and the officers involved in the arrest
of daniel prude
anthony all right eureka thank you very
much this shift in
police departments is very interesting
here yeah i think every time you always
hear
training in many cases training is the
go-to and i think that's what's so
frustrating to people because does
training say you just
leave your humanity at the door the fact
that that guy was buck naked in the
street says
instantly that there's an issue here and
it's snowing outside he's in trouble
snowing outside and his relatives have
called for help
and they end up with their brother their
their their father
their son now dead it just makes no
sense and it took so long
for the tape to come out yeah a lot of
questions in that could not agree more